what I really hope and I felt it
listening to those into incredible
leaders and our company is we've got a
real we got a real [ __ ] shot
[Music]
good morning vlog hey iris I go this way
because I'm no piddly vlog I've had an
epiphany I want to share it with you
I've been thinking a lot about something
which is the way I think about business
and this is gonna help a lot of you
which excites me and I miss you guys
it's been a whole lot of like hodgepodge
recalls and all that obviously with the
holidays and everything so it's good to
be back there's two ways to sell a
product
there's branding and marketing and their
sales and and all of you jump into one
or two buckets right like you really
understand the long marathon of building
a brand it's a lot about influencers
awareness it's content and there are a
lot of you are really great math kids
and it's like Amazon affiliates and and
Google and and quant based math like CAC
LTV CAC customer acquisition costs LTV
lifetime value math kids art kids
anthropology kids quant kids and and
that's how I think about business and
then I realized holy [ __ ] that is what
is going on with me and content a lot of
people producing content for a short
term ROI right they do a vlog cuz they
want to sell something whether it's
merchandise or or ebooks or things of
that nature and everybody wants to sell
and I want to sell my legacy I want I
want to I want reputation I want you
know a lot of the dirty stuff I do
meeting with you one-on-one DMing you
it's it's not ry+
I get a lot of accolades like Gary
replied Gary cares Gary called me Gary
gave me a chance Gary met with me and I
realize my behavior is because my North
Sora's legacy reputation what do you say
behind my back a lot of you first get a
hold of me and you're like I don't know
about this guy and I win in the long
term
over and over and over again because
intent and the truth always win and my
intent and my truth is I'm going for
legacy like the money is gonna come
along like you know there's a big
interesting thing about me I made my you
know family a lot of money in in you
know I always knew how to make money
fëanor media was a foregone conclusion
this is a hundred fifty hundred seventy
five million dollar holding company now
with Pierre Wow and vaynermedia vein or
X Bainer sports is a foregone conclusion
that company will make money it's it's
gonna do that by legacy like we're gonna
take care of our kids better which is
gonna cost us money in the short term
I'm holding my breath I'm not worried
about money in the short term and so I
am acting in my content in the intent of
legacy and that is wow I'm filtering
things and that's how I'm looking at
what you're doing are you looking for
long long-term legacy and brand which
then will bring you dollars or are you
looking for dollars in the short term do
you love the process of building that
brand or do you hate it and you're just
working for the dollar and it's just
this very obvious thing now and I never
put it really deeply into the content
part of what I'm doing and so because
content a lot of times has always been
about branding but I've realized as I've
analyzed a lot of you is your content is
actually sales content like you don't
really care about what you're putting
out you don't really care it's a it's
being done for something in return in a
short term and I think it's a huge
[ __ ] mistake and so when I say close
your eyes until twenty nine like I did
the other day or thirty nine or forty
nine or when I say you're 44 you have
time it's because I believe it it's I
believe that you're 44 years old
you uh you are not happy with your job
or things of that nature and I just
genuinely you know so crazy
like I'm looking at this like I wrote
this this came out in 2009 I think right
and I wrote it in 2008 so I wrote it ten
years ago that's a small little [ __ ]
and obviously I'm writing the follow-up
now but it's the punchline man like if
you do the right thing over what I think
is a long term to a lot of you five six
years you'll win you will win and so
live your life in a way put yourself in
a position where you don't need money
meaning you don't need stuff right or
even if you have debt or it sucks right
now put yourself into a cocoon and say
it doesn't matter it's gonna suck for
another thirty six months and then it's
gonna get better
these short-term moves are just
everybody's just like trying to close on
the first move and it never works not in
the long term negativity and and tactics
win in the short term positivity and
merit and the stake win in the long term
and there's confusion in the system and
I will systematically for the rest of my
life trying to unwind it and get people
unfuckin confused cool it's true right
well let pull on hold on like this is
what the blog is about like great so
we're still rolling like go ahead IRA so
what are you what are you saying why
were you just saying that yeah not that
I know what to do with this [ __ ] yeah
I'm aware
even like the titles for example on my
channel that's instead of you feel
better too
right so you're saying I'm gonna title
something please yes cuz you felt like
you were doing it to grow your shame
yeah yeah like I realized this being
with you right so you see me always
pushing down on these characters when
they're trying like d-roc especially is
bad at this he's always trying to do
things to like win you to because he
wants to win YouTube you know and I'm
always like [ __ ] you yeah [ __ ] you d-roc
nohow let me just get it now look uh
hold on
[ __ ] how do you guys do this okay okay
come on don't rehearse I got I'll figure
it out
[ __ ] you D rock bobby bowden do you like
that huh
is that your favorite did you also learn
that like you know like when you do the
true thing and the right thing like that
content will always do better not like
the hack or the thing like the rock
always wants to do like the hack for you
to write
Seth you agree like D rock is weird with
you - yeah d Rock why are you guys
trying to hack YouTube do you believe
that Alex do you believe that blog this
is the most important part where Tyler
and I make sure everything happens that
needs to happen
are you it's awesome and how are you
able to go such a pleasure come on in
this gives me energy
this gives me the energy that I need
[Music]
I think they all know I think they all
know it's true
[Music]
going to a meeting
are we gonna be really late anyway you
can fly real quick-like can you hit that
button I know that I know there's other
people in the room here now so we're
gonna show them that feature but I hate
being late more than anything
[Music]
Blagh what's up backer car been running
late all day heading out to LA today on
business and I have a company-wide all
hands-on meeting coming up to go through
some of the nuances of the business and
so stressed out a little bit got a new
pod sessions if you're not listening to
podcast you're making a huge mistake and
this new concept pod sessions kind of
like taking off the jam sessions that me
and my homies did in the early days of
kind of like web 2.0 grabbing three
people from random different backgrounds
putting them together putting them on
the podcast and shooting the [ __ ] so I'm
excited about doing that first one today
introduce you to three new people and
just got done with a meeting with a
client sitting in this traffic with of
what's the ETA now [ __ ] that's bad I was
18 minutes five minutes ago
so something bad happened running late
to meetings is literally the worst
feeling
[Music]
can this room kind of do me a favor and
just spread out and get everybody
because I'm coming
good afternoon vaynermedia thank you so
much I'm sorry I'm a little bit late
first and foremost I want to wish
everybody a healthy and happy 2018 I
hope everybody enjoyed their time off
that seems like a million years ago I'm
sure for all of you I see the hustle in
every avenue the things that we are
focused on as an organization are
clearly resonating with the marketplace
I think a lot of what the second bullets
about the way I think about our
continued obsession of long-form video
or video not even necessarily long-form
for mobile devices or where people are
paying attention to our enormous
momentum around voice and what is going
on in an Alexa Google home environment I
think what I'm most proud of is
vaynermedia obviously as pigeon-holed
still with many people as a social media
shop because any client service company
in the world in any sector is
pigeon-holed often into the services
they provide early on there's just a lot
of good going on and as I look at the
macro issues and opportunities at hand
for the biggest brands in the world
and I think we will be on the right side
of history and I'd love to hear a
massive clap for two of the most
essential parts of our company
[Applause]
and so excited to be here and I want to
share a little bit about why we join the
organization in panic what were what
we're up to such a senior can take it
off by Australia but I joined six months
ago and it's been a wild ride and I've
loved every minute of it very much
impressed me that man is at this
incredible inflection point but one of
the success that you've had in the last
day is as like it's bubbling energy of
what's come next and we're getting asked
to go and speak to quiet stop being that
AOR and that's a pretty epic feat for a
company not only of this size but also
this young in its its Genesis and I
think that opportunity is something I'm
really excited about because I
so welcome welcome so I'm one of the
proud members of the class of 2018 so
far enough to be here and I love the
program that the people experienced team
have delivered so far and I have to say
I came into this organization with
really high expectations and it's the
past ten days are anything like what the
experience is going to be going forward
having not only spent a little time here
but being out in CES where we were
interacting with some of the top sumos
in the in the world we are so positioned
at the right time for what the industry
needs and it's our provocative point of
view combined with the energy of our
people that is going to just nail it
echo what everybody saying in terms of
or I'm gonna try to lather it up just
one more time you put candy in my office
in between Steve and Osteen but these so
many of you have reached out and it
means the world to me
hope you guys are ready for 2018 who
knows yeah
[Applause]
the candy thing duck made me feel like I
wanna one-up it so going going forward I
have free cash in my office so hopefully
you guys will take me up on the
open-door policy a lot
look I you know this is super
interesting because for me so much of
what has brought me happiness in my life
personally and professionally has been
predicated on whether it's intuition or
pattern recognition it's having a good
sense of what's about to happen and then
building towards it you know what I want
what I really hope and I felt it
listening to those into incredible
leaders and our company is we've got a
real we got a real [ __ ] shot yeah
that's a good way to end I love you guys
yup hey blog just did a great uh way to
talk to the whole company I love them
very much Bobby Glenn in the house the
saying that was a big shout out for you
now I know thanks Brett
how to tell a good day we got that rant
earlier today you'll take some pieces
from this you'll use somebody to help
you edit it properly
see you later vlog
[Music]